hey this is Moshe kasher and Natasha
Leggero we just got married six months
ago which we think pretty much makes us
qualified to give love advice to
strangers so that's what we did we
packed up the car hit the road spread
the love
yes how's breakfast luxurious I've been
down there for two hours I found a cave
down there where there's a sea urchin
living why do you pretend like you don't
like loves very much you're clearly
having fun here you know that sea urchin
was hmm my my hell yeah I do like
luxury I just don't like the price point
I would rather spend more money on the
vacation than less money on anyway I'm
having a good done I think we really
helped people last night you really do
uh-huh yeah what's your name Maureen
Maureen and Russell do you have
something specific you'd like to address
so he doesn't like when my dog sleep in
the bed how many dogs do you have to but
they're tiny okay
and Ellis a Meier that's fair no I think
that's fair it doesn't matter because
it's not about the amount of size it's
about the idea right correct is the idea
is the fact that they bring in all this
stuff from their feet and they like
their own ass right I mean they're in
the bed and I'm just expected to sleep
there and so you have like anal
retentive issues OCD kind of very OCD I
happen to sleep with three chihuahuas
but he shouldn't be expected I do sleep
with three chihuahuas yeah I do
don't hug me I like dogs
I'm not your ally here I mean opposite
I'm anal I I'm I like anal whatever the
opposite is Moshe is opposite like he's
kind of messy so he doesn't care a bit
of a slob so I don't care about stuff
like if motional makes a mess he runs
away from it we really we've been
together for over a year now and just
I'm very committed to her but she
doesn't like the idea of commitment to
one person anyway it's about the dogs
no no it doesn't work like that
wait but that's interesting the your ear
a little bit you're a little bit
commitment phobic but we were asking of
him is for him to become incredibly
intimate with you by subverting his own
desires to have thee and let please dogs
in the bed yes no comma you you don't
want it you don't like the idea of being
committed to one person do you want to
be your thing you want to be open I did
but now you found someone you love and
your that's the same with me and and now
I don't want that anymore because I love
her so much more every day and the way
in was to allow her three dogs to sleep
in the bed with me dude and here's my
suggestions I have a suggestion
but here's for a month you put it by a
sheet the dog sheet okay put the dog
sheet over the comforter while you guys
are laying in bed watching movies bring
the dogs they get to hang out no
restrictions then when it's time for
sleep don't sex sleeping sex you bring
the dogs you let them lick your ass no
no you you let the dogs so the dogs stay
up like what he's saying that's good
during movie time and then go to your
spot are dogs by the way they know they
know the sound of our orgasms like we're
like go to your spot okay let me go down
there and they were like oh god which is
what it sounds like
come and then they just like jump back
up like okay cool it's on again
what could you deal with that I can deal
with that that sounds good when you be
willing to not sleep with your dogs or
any other people it is weird that we're
at a times like I relate to it where you
want to like sleep with a dog wait you
think that that weren't the era of Stog
sleeping around I think we're the era
where dogs replaced children for a lot
of people in their 30s and 40s and above
but I mean the reality of that was she
wanted a polyamorous relationship and
solution dogs dogs representing
everybody else hmm do you think that
woman wants to sleep with her dogs
because of her dream of polyamory I
think it's like a metaphor you know if
she's afraid of intimacy that keeping
the dogs there was a kind of like furry
wedge between her and her furry wedge uh
it's like you know to be psychologically
helpful for her I bet and W might guess
but that's so deep in her subconscious
that only only a really brilliant
psychologist like me could see that yeah
what's your nearest school Erin Erin is
Erin and Cameron so we've been together
the last two years and live together the
last year but now I'm going to CLA in
the fall and he's going back to the East
Bay Area I don't know we just kind of
want like ideas or suggestions for
making a long-distance relationship work
okay and why are you going back to
Salamone I didn't do great in school
here so I'm gonna get my together
back home say okay you're a city ecology
party too hard and now you're going back
home to get your together yes and
you're going to UCLA to meet a different
day
that's what I'm worried about all right
you know this thing the sleeper bus it's
this new thing where you pay 60 bucks
and you leave you leave Oakland at like
11:00 at night and you get into LA like
4:00 in the morning I'm gonna suggest
sleeper bus commitment for three out of
four weekends if for love that's what I
think yeah I could do that and don't
don't get a job where you have to work
weekends
you can have those weekends off and
really you know you might want to ask
her to marry you so she feels guilty so
she'll never I mean honestly I'm not
sure that's the right idea for you but
homie that is a great idea for you one
thing I will say is that long-distance
relationships over too long they it
starts to that whole that absence makes
the heart grow fonder
not now UCLA makes the girl wetter
and so the Keuka Boulder came up last
night I felt bad for him right because
like they both clearly moved to Santa
Barbara to try to go to school they both
went to Santa Barbara City College he
decided to major in malt liquor and she
decided to do her schoolwork to get in
the UCLA he's moving home to go be with
his family probably going to rehab or
something and she's going to UCLA to go
join a real school and like meet her
intellectual equals and stuff while he
like moves been to this pic this is to
me I mean it's the reality reality sucks
reality bites I'm gonna write a movie
called that seriously I'm thinking about
it who is your favorite couple last
night you me
Bo's yeah let's hit the road bro we
gotta drive all the way to Palm Springs
today and that's a four and a half hour
drive okay I have an idea
okay in the Dasha how about you guys
move in with each other
all right you stop doing that weird
thing with your water